le défilé annuel du 9 mai en russie pour
fêter les 75 ans de la victoire sur
l'allemagne nazie n'a pas eu lieu cette
année crise sanitaire oblige
mais le cortège aura bel et bien lieu
vladimir poutine annonçant un report
pour le mois de juin la correspondance à
moscou d'antonne claireaux antoine les
célébrations du 9 mai sont donc reportés
et une nouvelle date vient d'être
annoncée oui le 9 mai dernier au plus
fort de la crise du coronavirus en
russie seul le volet aérien de la parade
militaire avait été maintenu le reste
étant reportée à une date ultérieure et
cette date justement vient d'être
annoncée et par vladimir poutine lors
d'une de ces vidéos conférences
hebdomadaires ce sera donc le 24 juin
écoutez je crois qu'il est possible de
prendre la décision suivante
j'ordonne de commencé les préparations
pour le défilé militaire en l'honneur du
75e anniversaire de la victoire lors de
la grande guerre patriotique dont la
capitale du pays à moscou et dans
d'autres villes
le défilé aura lieu le 24 juin c'est le
jour où le légendaire défilé historique
des vainqueurs a eu lieu en 1945 quand
les soldats qui ont combattu près de
moscou est défendue leningrad qui ont
combattu près de stein wydad libéré
l'europe et qui ont pris berlin dassault
qui ont traversé la place rouge
[Musique]
un défilé qui il a demandé se fera dans
le respect des exigences de sécurité les
plus strictes
depuis plusieurs années à la suite de la
parade militaire on assiste normalement
à la marche du régime rpt immortel cette
immense foule d'anonymes qui défile avec
à la main le portrait d'un proche ayant
participé à la grande guerre patriotique
comme on appelle ici la seconde guerre
mondiale et bien cet événement aura bien
lieu mais plus tard le 26 juillet afin
de réduire encore davantage le risque de
contamination parmi la population
d'ici là les autorités espèrent bien que
la progression de la pandémie sera
définitivement enrayée
les chiffres les plus récents sont les
suivants 8915 nouveaux cas ces dernières
24 heures pour un total de 360 milles
qu'un et c'est maintenant le 11e jour
c'est cutif à moins de dix mille
nouveaux cas signe que le pic paraît
bien être franchi
le bilan humain lui s'élève à 3807 morts
depuis le début de la pandémie et la
russie ça à faire également sur le front
de la recherche médicale
le ministre de la défense a déclaré
qu'une nouvelle état venait d'être
franchi dans la mise au point d'un
vaccin a écouté l'institut central des
forces de défense chimiques et
biologiques numéro 48 du ministère de la
défense et le centre national de
recherche d'épidémiologie et de
microbiologie gamaleya développe un
vaccin recombinant contre la nouvelle
infection du coronavirus à l'heure
actuelle les spécialistes de l'institut
achève les recherche pré clinique du
vaccin expérimental
la date de fin de travaux est prévu pour
le 1er juin
les recherches précliniques devrait être
achevée d'ici à la fin du mois de
juillet la tenue des célébrations du 9
mai revêt une grande importance non
seulement pour l'avenir poutine mais
aussi pour tout le peuple russe et les
autorités on le voit font tout pour que
cet événement se tiennent le plus
rapidement possible merci antoine
claireaux en direct donc de moscou pour
tous ces prix